I'm Sarah I'm Frank we are going to be
filming ourselves running at night okay
I can run at night no baby I'm not
scared you know
of course not of course not told
this kind of shaded and dark at night
it's New York City so anything can
happen dreams can come true a nightmare
soon
there was this recent survey in runner's
world that found that 58 percent of
female runners were harassed while
running
does that sound high to you yeah it's
outrageous
another Gallup poll showed that 50
percent of women polled were afraid to
even walk at night in their own
neighborhoods that's why after hearing
about all these women being assaulted
while running at night I don't know
whether that's a fear that I I should
have I first emailed out looking if
anybody would run at night I was
surprised at how many men responded and
how no women responded I had no one
it was my video so I was like well if
somebody has to do it I guess I have to
do it before you started doing this
experience did you tell people oh I'm
doing this yeah actually I took a
Instagram poll on for my followers and
to see if it's a smart idea a lot of
them say said that it's not a really
smart move why run at night I put
yourself out there in that risk and the
ones that were like interested for drama
definitely pushed me towards running at
night when I started to tell some people
I was doing this everyone was like no
what are you doing don't do it I had
friends that were texting me Sarah are
so stupid like it's not worth it and my
husband in particular was like very
freaked out by it
he thought that by doing this and doing
it because I was interested in the
experience I was going to be somehow
inviting negative things to happen to me
like while I was running I usually run
three to four miles every other day I
could travel no three four miles please
for miles sometimes five I'm pushing it
but you usually do treadmill yeah always
doing the treadmill I prefer to run
outside or on a track when I do run
which is admittedly
not as often and not as far I'm going to
start running tonight as you guys can
see it's midnight and I'm kind of
nervous because currently I don't see
anyone in this place and I'm just kind
of worried that if I were to spook for
help in case of any emergencies I'm not
sure if I would see anyone come to the
rescue
it's freaky I felt relatively safe
because my first trial was in like a
very well-off neighborhood it's like by
the Westside
okay so just water and there's the
highway and buildings
I looked up tips for running at night
and somebody said like run with your dog
I'm gonna go on my first run tonight I
think I'm gonna try going with Lucy I
think having her with me maybe will make
it easier they've probably met like a
big dog yeah I've been tiny dogs so
that's not what they meant
they also said like Oh run with you know
pepper spray these were off for like
wreck women running like women running
at night and I did find an article that
was like an article from a male
perspective he thought meals shouldn't
run at night was because you might fall
and injure yourself and I just thought
that was really funny
I was actually super surprised at how
many people I saw running there were so
many people at the park that were
running late at night and it made me
feel much better like I was like oh my
god so many people do this I you know
there's no reason to be afraid at night
it's so cool it feels so much better to
be outside running than it would be in
the middle of the day see other people
run at night and they're women so that
also makes me feel better
I understand why we would be afraid to
ride a night I never sing get it but I
also from this experience feel like if
you have a place that is safe or there's
a lot of people I don't think you should
let that stop you I'm hearing all this
music and I'm running in the park
there's some event going on I mean
anytime you feel less alone when you're
running I think it's a good thing
surprisingly there were like only a few
people around I just run two miles I
only saw a total of three people during
the whole entire journey to be honest I
was kind of shocked because I was
expecting more people who are suspicious
whereas you like selling like drugs or
something like by the water I don't know
I don't know I was expecting something
weird so the second trial I decided to
run closer to home it was a little bit
dark and shady and there were not as
many streetlights
there were moments where I felt really
unsafe I definitely took precautions
everything I wore was as neutral as it
can be so sometimes I the gym I might
wear a pink tank so just to make sure
that I don't invite hostility or any
reason I just chose our neutral color
like for females if you don't want
invite cat collars and harasses that
kind of idea of trying to wear neutral
things that don't make you stand out in
some way to invite attention I think
about it too
yeah yeah it shouldn't have to happen
for either of us the parks nice let me
try different room so I actually went to
a bar class and I decided I was gonna
run out instead of being just like
pleasant neighborhood it's like I've ran
gently Avenue like that it's a very bit
it's busy honestly the fact that there
were so many people that maybe
not feel that uncomfortable there really
is safety in numbers my concern was less
about my physical safety more of the
safety the equipment cause like I said I
did feel like yet you were inviting
unwanted attention because of that so as
you can see there's this like blinking
light that's following me everywhere I
go like you're not wearing a bright
colored shirt so you don't get attention
but you're wearing a camera that has a
red light that's [ __ ] yeah that's
unpleasant attention human flashlight
you know running around I felt scared at
points but I was expecting to be more
scared and then the weekend happen I
wasn't running didn't have the GoPro on
but I had I parked our car like farther
away from our house and usual because I
drove back from somewhere it was late at
night like 1:00 a.m. and I got the car
had my dog big bag and there was like a
guy there and he started like talking to
me
he was obviously drunk and I felt very
uncomfortable started talking to me
asking for my number and I was trying to
be gracious or whatever I don't know I
was trying not to think of that I was
just kind of like no no I don't think so
I don't do that
but then he like followed me he followed
me towards my apartment at this point
I'm thinking okay well don't go to your
apartment
no no you live but I had my dog with me
and she was like I tried to walk by my
apartment my dog was like what are you
doing I was like umm this is obvious and
I I've coded entry so I was like I don't
want him to see me putting my coat in oh
if I said like get the hell away from me
go away like he's obviously inebriated I
don't know what he's gonna do
I made it inside and I shut the door and
I don't know I was just like literally
had to lie down because I was so like on
edge when I start to think about it I'm
like Sarah what are you doing is it
really worth doing this because I think
before that happened I was gonna kind of
say these fears are overblown
if you want to run at night run at night
but then after that happened I
definitely I changed my mind I felt like
okay I don't know the solution I don't
know the answer if you would war and
like a bright pink shirt what's like
your worst fear of what would have
happened I would be worried this person
could be potentially homophobic if they
were to like attack me or like harass me
and that's the last thing that one do
you think women are LGBTQ or anybody do
you think they should be running outside
at night even though it might be an
intimidating environment if you want to
run at night definitely take
precautionary measures and just have a
back-up plan
my recommendation probably would be to
run with a group safety numbers but also
it's a group activity makes you more
likely to keep doing it and I understand
the fear but I think I would rather live
in a world where we all can feel
comfortable running at night and I would
like to work in that direction this bad
stuff does happen but I don't think we
should let it rule us I think we should
take control of it
[Music]